est ce que vous vous avez déjà eu un mec
voilà qu'il y avait un truc qui me dana
tue l'amour un truc que vous aimez bien
le mien et puis il y avait un truc qui
passait pas il ya un truc voilà qui a
fait que ça c'est fini vous non mal en
moins et avaient un garçon qui me
plaisait énormément visiblement c'était
assez réciproque sauf qu'il avait les
ongles noirs et ça franchement ça veut
dire que l'hygiène et récolte les abou
show si on m'avait dit oui c'était le
rouge et donc je me suis dit l'hygiène
doit pas être génial et pourtant ils
étaient autant vous dire mais vraiment
sublime mais ils devaient se dire que
justement comme il était parfois ballard
bowl un dessert des gens c'est ça aussi
c'est oui non oui c'est l'hygiène
buccale peut-être d'un souci les rachats
mais les aulas veut dire que tu te lave
pas les mains sales crown ses voix
mêlées mais vous et c'était vraiment un
mec comme ça d'un cancer à mort c'est
que moi très important l'hygiène non
mais c'est vrai il ya des mecs des fois
et même des moines et des mois on le dit
souvent des fois quand on aime ça peut
m'arriver très chaud c'est comme si tu
avais du cul d une babouche mais l'atout
d'accès comme si tu avais un magasin de
cuir et la vraie question c'est comment
le comment le dire à l'autre tu es à
bailleul à maudire dire est celle où la
guerre directe des femmes et à tous les
autres vous le dirais pas bah vous
voudriez vous devriez madame oui s'il
s'était musique art médical encore c'est
que lorsqu'on parle des des doigts sales
des hommes généralement ça peut donner
de fortes maladie lors de pratiques
sexuelles envers les femmes je n'ai
entendu de galles m6 ya pas longtemps
d'accord et c'est très sérieux et
justement vous faire attention mais les
filles à vos copains et vous marrer
parce que les ongles salsa d'un accord
donc il faut avant de 48 bois c'est donc
[Rires]
c'est la llc le seul le cam est à droite
ça va donner je finis je finis dont je
suis la mère d'amélie top model par des
cap alpha c'est ben bella merci en tout
cas merci
témoignage